[Music]
you
welcome everybody it is earlier than
normal Donald Trump today opting instead
of a White House coronavirus press
briefing with the full White House press
corps he instead is doing a 3:00 p.m.
Eastern Rose Garden
I guess presentation about PPP and small
business with only limited White House
press so this is accomplishing two
things that were reported over the
weekend number one that Donald Trump was
going to be paring down access to him
for the press corps and by limiting this
I actually have Trump schedule here as
you can see this is restricted in-house
pool oh and it's actually it's not even
in the East Room it's actually in the
it's not in the Rose Garden it is in the
East Room so I should update that update
titles let's see here for today's
streams so it is actually White House
press conference not Rose Garden okay
updating that very good I could have
sworn as a very recently it was
scheduled for the Rose Garden maybe I
saw that incorrectly maybe it was indeed
changed and number two we were told
trump was going to be focusing more and
more on an economic message instead of a
virus message because he's calculated
and people around him probably have
calculated if you just talk about
business you it is less likely you will
say crazy crap like we should hit the
body with you know disinfectants and
that type of thing so it's happening
even though it was denied the reports
were denied over the weekend that Donald
Trump was going to be doing this he is
doing exactly that which it was reported
he would be doing so we are standing by
for that at roughly the top of the hour
monitoring a number of different feeds
PBS News says that they will be carrying
this Fox News says they will be carrying
this this is the Washington Post says
they will be carrying this also Joe
Biden Joseph R Biden Jr has a virtual
Town Hall on women's issues scheduled
for the top of the hour and we will keep
an eye on that potentially depending on
on what goes down and
how it all goes down but in the meantime
I have a little bit of time during which
I can answer some questions from you
guys including via YouTube super chat
and twitch messages yesterday during the
stream twitch went down completely and
of course people started contacting me
like I did something wrong and it's like
no twitch was just down down twitch had
a brownout I would say for lack of a
better term and for whatever reason I
was the target of a lot of Wrath but it
had nothing to do with me just twitch
went down but I am really glad that it
is back up today so people like Dana
Brown and Hunter Winky and Neil lip as
well as Wintermute and mark white all
can sign up with twitch subscriptions
and twitch prime subscriptions very very
exciting and I'm glad that people are
able to do that okay let's see what some
early super chatters are saying as a
hype train gets going over on twitch a
zesty African says David Pakman more
like David cool man it would be cool to
have left leading figures discuss
international politics on each other's
platform would you find a conversation
with Michael Brooks on Latin American
politics productive I have no idea I
don't know what he has to say about that
and Latin American politics are not my
area of focus either so it's hard to say
whether that would be productive
waffles derp awful says got a negative
Corona test result today Germany my city
1 million only two testing spots no
appointment didn't even need to wait one
other person interesting
Daniel Rivera says hurry up I need to
know my political opinions today Alex
Jones says Alex Jones Hugh Jass and holy
fook is back ok
Daniel Rivera says loved the show are
you more atheist or agnostic I feel like
the terms are often used interchangeably
and even if they were not originally
meant they have distinct meanings
they're often used interchangeably I'm
open to the idea that there is something
there I has just not been shown to me so
evidence would convince me whether that
what that
makes me you tell me my friends Alex
Jones says this one is for Bridget
Harding judge Jeanine is here back and
ready to defend Trump at all costs
please don't MIT ban me Bridget all
right so I all sorts of things going on
which I'm not even privy to Robert
Mifflin says did you hear about Andrew
Gilliam what are your thoughts if you
mean that he was found in a hotel room
hi a couple months ago I did hear about
it if something else happened then I
have not heard about it I mean I don't I
don't what is there to say really
Andrew Dwyer says if you are looking for
another book to read during kovat 19
triangle the fire that changed America
is a pretty good book by David von der
le I am finishing up right now as far as
from the standpoint of as I like to say
from the standpoint of nonfiction I am
finishing up The Secret Life of lobsters
which is very interesting and I'm
starting to read a book about the I
don't know if it's pronounced o sage or
OSA JH murders from the 1920s that I
think it's by David David grand David
brand something like that
forget the author anyway I'm only about
20 pages in and it's excellent already
excellent already a rich ropa thak says
Tufts is better than Brandeis okay I
have no connection to either school
couldn't tell you Anthony Sanchez says
where's bad that oh you know yeah I
don't know maybe he'll call in this week
nasty question says yesterday proved
Trump cannot resist nasty questions oh
oh oh speaking of which so somebody
today during this brief press avail
called out Trump about the fact that
when he says we've done the most tests
that per capita we haven't and Trump
pulls the who you with who do you work
for thing it's so predictable at this
point and then by the way at this point
dr. Burks is just a vector of
disinformation Trump turns to her and
she puts out a whole bunch of BS take a
look at this
has done five times more tests than the
US per capita why is that I don't think
that's true that is true and you said
this morning that the White House said
the u.s. passes South Colonie virus
testing who are you with
Yahoo News and it's not true per capita
trump strategy is I don't believe that
and shifting off to somebody else now
dr. Burks unfortunately just the esses
take a look remember early on we push
tests to the outbreak areas just like he
described his primary outbreak was in
Miami Dade and Broward County and Palm
Beach so they pushed tests into that
region we did the same thing in the
United States so if you look at every
single state that had an outbreak their
testing is greater than anywhere in the
world right you you prevent so now
understand how she's slicing and dicing
she's now saying you can pick the areas
that were hit earliest and they got
tests now we don't have the data in
order to fact-check that right in front
of us but that's a new argument that's a
different argument the way you prevent
new subsequent outbreaks is widespread
testing this is just a it's a new it's a
post facto rationalization to say okay
well even if we don't have the highest
national per capita testing here's some
other way we can kind of BS our way out
of really being accountable for that or
per you know forty two per thousand
raise your point just taken about
individual areas but overall we've had
14 times more infections than South
Korea so are we doing something wrong
and why is that they have a very dense
population excellent reporter by the way
not thrown off by the BS our epidemic
looks much more like the European
epidemic so right now we're tracking
very close to the countries in Europe
and we're testing at their rate of their
concentrate
epidemics and where they're occurring in
the metros I think it really shows the
susceptibility so I understand that now
we've got well if you compare our hot
spots to the European hot spots our
testing today even though they were four
to five weeks ahead of us is roughly
what what is the meaning of that I hope
people are understanding how deceptive
this is of our major cities in the same
way they were susceptible in Europe and
so we've been very focused on that
that's not the same we're very much
supporting the rural states and very
much supporting their testing there's no
there's no state right now in the United
States that's tested really less than 1%
which is pretty remarkable when they
don't really have significant cases ok
so again no state has tested much less
than 1% we're months in we're months and
what are you talking about so again you
know we we we look at the data and you
look at tests per million in the
population and we're very very far I
mean look at how far down you have to
scroll to get down to us right below
belgium and above the Cayman Islands
above Belarus below Canada below
Australia saying you know these are not
these these are not tiny countries in
any sense of the word so it's actually
sad that dr. Burks or dr. bricks as she
was referred to by I think it was
Admiral of check that they are she is
now a vector of disinformation and we
can't trust her and foul she's gone and
so that's that's where we are right now
it's sad
but this is where we are right now yes
she has kissed the ring so to speak as
Jabby Gatz is mentioning on on twitch ok
other super chats coming in Charlie says
cubic zirconia and polyester headed for
cabinet positions I don't know who those
people are
a rich ropa that says MIT is better than
Harvard yeah I don't know I have no idea
constitutional peasant says David thank
you for walking through this matter
with us I don't think I could listen
without your live fact-checking
also where is kim jeong-hoon we don't
know we don't know reports ranging from
everything is fine - he's dead
pick where you want to fall on that
Pepa's has subscribed on YouTube Andrew
Hodge says have you tried psilocybin
turns out it's easy to find God I have
not tried psilocybin no I have not if
you have a question or a comment for me
feel free to submit it using the super
chat function if you are watching on
YouTube of course let me go over to
twitch where I want to say a big thank
you to Mark white for subscribing with
twitch prime Timothy TM for subscribing
with twitch prime and you shy for
cheering question for everybody it has
been recommended to me that I reach out
to mixer hello Microsoft's live
streaming platform and that I explore
whether they would be interested in
making a play for my live streams now my
live streams are you know nothing to
write home about so I don't know that
they would actually be interested but I
am exploring the possibility of adding
mixer to the mix for lack of a better
term and I really know nothing about it
my the idea is mixers pouring money into
marketing themselves and as far as I
know there's not much news in politics
happening over there so it's an
opportunity maybe to do something new so
reports about that incoming we have a
number of irons in the fire with mixer
and maybe I'm completely kidding maybe
I'm completely kidding or maybe tomorrow
you'll see me live streaming on mixer we
don't know ok we are standing by for a
Trump East Room presentation about how
PPP is great for small businesses in the
era of coronavirus my instinct is that
what Trump is trying to do is to number
one get out of asking questions and
number two just focus on the economic
message because it's far better than the
medical message where we now have over 1
million confirmed cases we are just days
from hitting 60,000 deaths or
Trump told us we would have 60,000
deaths total we're going to hit it this
week and we still have you know tens of
thousands of cases that we are finding
every single day so I I believe that we
are about to see a real propaganda show
in the East Room of the White House and
we will see if any questions are asked
my guess is the answer will be no no
questions will be asked
okay other super chats coming in
dark-skinned romeo sends a super chat
from canada thomas Powell says 1800
watching only 250 likes yes if you're
watching on YouTube remember don't I I
want to be better than these right-wing
nut streams so you know we've seen what
happens sometimes you know there's
channels that engage in the battle of
ideas and stuff like that they're like
ratio is very very low we want to crush
them so if you're watching on YouTube
make sure to hit that like button make
sure to hit that subscribe button very
very exciting stuff pear tieran says he
means diamond and silk okay Brandon
diamond has subscribed on YouTube Bamber
kitty says you said in a previous video
that Neil Cavuto was fired from Fox News
is that true no I immediately after said
I'm just kidding they're like literally
in that because I wanted to avoid
anybody thinking I was being serious I
said of course Neil Cavuto has been
fired from Fox News I'm kidding of
course and then I moved on with the
segment so that didn't happen that
didn't happen
Dean Oldfield sends a super chat pair
tieran says I think you can't have mixer
and twitch they are fierce competitors
Robert Mifflin says what do you think
was the last okay United States invasion
was it Serbia uh I don't know that I
would say that I'd have to think about
that a little bit okay Vasile Vanda says
sad briefings are easing because they
hurt mango man yeah it seems as though
people close to Trump have actually
convinced him you were doing damage to
yourself by doing all of these
things and by taking all of these
questions and apparently Donald Trump
has taken that to heart and of course
today as you will notice no press
briefing often those look like this
yesterday's of course was canceled and
replaced with a news conference instead
today we have just actually I'll refresh
this to see if it's changed it is not
today the president delivers remarks on
supporting our nation's small businesses
through the Paycheck protection program
notice this restricted in-house pool so
that is very different than a full press
corps event I would not be surprised
that Trump doesn't take a single
question and it is merely merely a
propaganda event let me see if c-span is
going to be carrying it not yet let's
see if we look at White House YouTube
channel and see if they I presume they
will be carrying it yes here it is
okay so that has not started yet either
so we're keeping an eye on it and we
will see when it when it actually starts
let me say thank you to gut she who has
subscribed with twitch Prime at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman I also want
to say thanks to Marcia Ballard Marcia
is new member number one today at join
pakman.com Thank You Marcia I so
appreciate your support very very much
so okay a few other super chats coming
in here let me make sure I don't miss
anybody
monique de lu that looks like a Dutch
name to me I wonder if we have a new
Dutch member welcome mind melt says if
we continue electing the centrist is the
party going to continue to get more
corporate and right which party are you
referring to right Alonzo's olan's has
subscribed on YouTube
Michael Hank Lee says what to do if
insurance won't cover Lysol injection
take that as a sign that it may not be
medically advisable danny thompson hey
Danny Danny says David my name is Danny
and I am a boy pack man
oh boy I am especially addicted to your
live streams with Co vid 45 something
about this message is cracking me up has
anyone else coined the term PAC maniac
before or am I the first thanks for all
you do I think I have seen the term
floating around on reddit but it's
usually spelled with a k like my name
brandon diamond says I am in Nova Scotia
where Massacre was 22 dead yeah we
covered that horrible horrible story on
the bonus show I think it was last week
we covered it but it was an ugly story
very very ugly tragic Charlie says Trump
trying to pronounced Cepheid is a top-10
moment yeah let me see if we can find
that that is that was an unbelievable
moment I think Aaron probably posted
that let's see if we can find it
actually you know what I think I posted
it to my Twitter page this was the most
interesting moment yesterday uh here it
is
and Cephei feft sefa Hyde Dickinson ho
logic and cefe FF sefa hi it actually
almost sounds like a Hebrew word which
is really really funny for no particular
reason it's just funny but that was that
was amazing and of course let me pull up
I can find B the company Trump was
talking about of course is Cepheid I
actually I don't even really know how
it's pronounced but I know it's not safe
Safa hide molecular testing they do the
expert Express SARS Co V to test with
rapid detection beautiful beautiful test
perfect test I would even say let's look
at that just one more I just love this
is so good Dickinson ho logic and SEF a
FF sefa hi why why do I love that why do
I love that why do I just I have to do
it one more time and then we're gonna
move on and cephei
Feb 7 and the way Trump's mouth like
look right here of I don't know what the
hell I'm doing is is very very funny
okay now someone yesterday I was looking
at so let me give you a little bit of
info yesterday how much did I say about
this yesterday I was supposed to be in
LA on the Joe Rogan program and because
it would be very responsible to fly out
and the flight I had was canceled anyway
and bla bla bla bla bla let me just make
sure we're not missing anything here no
not yet okay I didn't I wasn't out there
and I was supposed to appear with Tim
Poole and Tim drove out there which
which was not something that was in the
in the cards for me and he actually was
tested for the virus at Joe Rogan's
studio and it was negative it was
negative and so I started looking around
and I guess there is a a - corona virus
antibody test this company a ytu I don't
know how it's pronounced a - bioscience
makes these tests and I would be
interested in ordering some of them if
it's even possible but then when I went
to try to order them on this website it
said that I need it where was it here
order request form I guess like you kind
of need to be a doctor sort of to order
this and you know you need a license or
sir I don't have any of this stuff so
I'm just I'm merely talking out loud I
don't want to restrict access to anybody
who you know to anybody but I would be
interested in getting one of those tests
if anybody knows where lay people can
can order them maybe email me if you
know anything about that
or let me know via super chat I'd be
interested in that I guess yeah I guess
you for whatever reason that you're
supposed to be a doctor to order
antibody tests which is weird you would
think they would just sell them over the
counter it's strange okay other super
chats coming in Jesse bear says what
number what number would
Crump need to personally mask up I don't
know that Trump would ever mask up quite
quite frankly parity run says PAC maniac
here thanks pare great to see you
Timothy Matthews sends a super chat
Danny Thompson says many apologies for
the misspelling PAC maniac or PAC maniac
with a k it is Chris K has upgraded his
membership to beta Stephen Perot says
hey David do you know where New
Brunswick is by any chance I'm watching
the press conferences because they're
hilarious
when is this one starting scheduled for
ten minutes ago and we don't know what
is going on
looks like Washington Post has some kind
of pre-show thing let me refresh that
and see what's going on but yeah nothing
um nothing big going on there yet also
Joe Biden has a wait a second did this
end already what is this worries about
just making ends meet and millions more
and women are on the front lines as
health care workers doctors nurses
sanitation workers child care workers
grocery store clerks worker what on
earth is going on here someone is
scrolling something else it's a it's a
recursive streaming situation what the
hell is going on oh my god all right
let's go to live oh ok so we'll keep an
eye on that that seems to be starting
soon
no news yet on the Trump event I just
want to see a few seconds of what Joe
Biden is doing here and we'll take a
look very interesting stuff who knows
what to expect right
okay
hey guys you know what I think this was
pre-recorded I think they might be
pretending this is live because just
before it started did you see how we saw
someone scrolling a video of Biden
talking to Hillary hold on [ __ ] on time
for Americans all across the nation more
than 50 South 57,000 lives lost more
than 26 million Americans of 5'4
unemployment
we're all worried about our health and
our families and women are experiencing
much of a pandemic devastating impacts
more than anything else
millions of women have lost their jobs
and had their hours slept front lines as
health care workers doctors nurses
sanitation workers childcare workers
grocery store clerks worker huh this is
really weird health care workers doctors
nurses sanitation here does a got your
workers so it looks like they're
pretending this is live it says live but
we just saw that they accidentally
started playing this about 15 minutes
ago so it looks like it's fake live
they're claiming it's live well it's
obviously not we just watched more
carrying on their backs the rest of the
nation domestic violence survivors are
at a heightened risk force the shelter
in place when it doesn't impact every
community equally it hits hard as those
who are most vulnerable and who have the
fewest resources including women of
color and low-income women this pandemic
is pulling back the curtain on so many
inequities in our society the lack of
paid sick leave for workers the need for
livable minimum wage the need for
stronger unemployment insurance
guys I I don't know that this is that
great and I think that we just caught
them pretending that something is live
which it like I see people in the chat
saying well it was it was live at some
point they're claiming it's live now
that's the problem I think and that that
is extremely concerning to me we are
still standing by for the start of this
Donald Trump event momentarily that is
weird that is that is really really
weird and I'm not I'm not totally sure
what to make of that
yikes yikes
okay Timothy mashup Matthews says when
did you cover sexual assault allegation
Biden I believe it was late last week on
stream Deborah Pierson has subscribed at
the SOI boy level Fazil Vanda says our
drugs or senility to blame for Trump's
brain I don't know could be both Ms
Smith says another day and more crap
from the king of crap Trump have you
seen the meme of Trump's head sculpted
from horse manure I have not seen that I
have not seen that Chris K says Biden is
always so awkward live or not yeah I I
mean this is this is weird stuff guys
held by women in our country has been
classified as essential so this is an
issue that affects all of us young and
old every kind of background from every
walk of life but it is having a
disproportionate impact on the front
lines on women working on women caring
for others on women holding down the
home as we go through this together so I
want to add my voice to the many who
have endorsed you to be our president
just think of what a difference it would
make right now if we had a president who
not only listened to the science but
facts / fiction but brought us together
showed the kind of compassion and caring
that we need from our president and has
been exemplifying throughout his entire
life think of what it would mean if we
had a real president not just somebody
who plays one on TV
but somebody who gets up every morning
worried about the people that he's
responsible for leading during this
crisis well I know what a difference it
would make because I've been there I've
seen firsthand what presidents can and
should do and I like so many Americans
really wished that we had that kind of
leadership now you know Joe Biden has
been preparing for this moment his
entire of life she's almost talking as
if she's not
connected with Biden like as if it was
separately recorded in some way it's
just it's everything about this feels
not great to me and you all know I'm
voting for Biden I watched him build
coalitions and work to bring people
together to solve problems then during
the Obama administration when I was
privileged to be Secretary of State I've
been in the Situation Room with Joe as
we debated and you know where we didn't
say what we thought people wanted to
hear we said what we believed and we had
a president then with President Obama
who encouraged that think of it we
wanted to hear from each and every one
of us I've been in the you know lobbying
guys I have to admit I'm not even live
right now this was actually recorded
earlier and producer Pat is playing a
recording of a live stream from earlier
today
all right so Hillary endorsing Biden I
genuinely don't know how much it's going
to help Joe Biden
I think the dynamics of this election
are different and and I just in general
I'm skeptical of of endorsements looks
like this is getting going here but I
just in these particular cases I just
don't know how much this is going to
help all right so we've got this looks
like heavy propaganda people standing up
what is going on now what is happening
here this is this is already weird
okay
here's Trump oh my god is Ivanka
participating in something you have got
to be kidding me
all right we're gonna switch over to the
c-span feed up by the way I will be
thanking people new members right after
this is over please do consider grabbing
a membership at join pakman.com we have
a 66% off code and one person has signed
up I would love it if it were 25 and
everybody will get a thank you as this
is vile and toxic this is violent toxic
well thank you very much everyone this
is a great honor and I see you have
social distance on your mind
and that's a very good thing Joe Beda
congratulations tremendous job you're
doing I want to thank everyone for being
at the White House a very special house
a very special place no matter where you
go in the world they love the White
House and being here in the East Room of
the White House in particular with so
many important functions have taken
place over the years functions have
taken place over the years and today
we're really celebrating American
workers and small businesses and we've
done a job for you and we're gonna make
it so as we open up our country you're
going to be in good shape as opposed to
be either losing your business or how do
we get some people to work here
especially since your employees were so
good over the years and those are the
ones you wanted so we made that possible
for you we're delighted to be joined
this afternoon by representatives of
several incredible small businesses from
across our country also with us our
Treasury Secretary Stephen minuchin this
is total propogate
an SBA administrator
you've been busy Steve by the way a
little bit right broke every record in
the book an SBA administrator Jovita
Carranza Thank You Jovita have you got
to sleep in the last two weeks I don't
think so right you broke every single
lending record numbers of loans amount
of loans small business sexually a very
big business when you think about it
great job oh it's active as our nation
battles against this terrible scourge or
continue to pray for the victims as well
as for those Americans who are grieving
their lost ones and their loved ones
there's never been anything like this we
suffer with one heart but we will
prevail we're coming back and we're
coming back strong we built the greatest
economy anywhere in the world two months
ago and we're gonna build it again we're
gonna build it fast it's gonna go very
quickly and Larry thank you for being
here very much it's you see what's going
to happen I think you have the same
feeling as I do it's going to come back
very fast now that our experts believe
the worst days of the pandemic are
behind us Americans are looking forward
to the safe and rapid reopening of our
country throughout this ordeal millions
of hardworking Americans have been asked
to really make tremendous presentó
delije safe propaganda setting for Trump
can you imagine this is what they're
replacing press briefings with we
thought would ever be talking about
something like this his virus has
inflicted an enormous and painful toll
on our nation's workers and small
businesses that's why last month I asked
Congress to pass the Paycheck protection
program giving small businesses
emergency economic relief to keep
workers on the payroll for weeks ago I
was proud to sign it into law we did
that at a great ceremony with many of
the people here and the officials here
and it was something and I can tell you
I'm gonna ask Steve to say a few words
but the kind of numbers and the kind of
jobs they've done and the kind of jobs
that have also been saved it's
incredible you'll be seeing that in the
coming I guess we won guys the Treasury
Department and the Small Business
Administration launched the program in
record-breaking time just one week and
in the 14 days following its launch we
processed as many loans as the SBA were
typically processed at over 14 years
so in 14 days they did more work and
more loans both in terms of applications
and in terms of dollar amount than they
did in 14 years 14 days 14
years easy one to remember right that's
some record I'd want to first without
the funding provided more than 1.6
million small businesses with over 340
billion dollars so that American workers
can retain their jobs receive their
paychecks and help our economy take off
quickly once America reopens for
business which is happening right now as
we sit we're gonna be all set you
already know I can I know you know I
talked to you back that you ready
you folks are ready our swift action
supported or say hello thirty million
American jobs at least and last week
Congress answered our call to replenish
the program and I was honored to sign an
additional 320 billion dollars for
American workers into law at least sixty
billion dollars are reserved for
community financial institutions
including those that serve minority and
distressed communities and that's also
when you think it's African American
communities it's Hispanic American
communities it's Asian American
communities we began accepting
applications for the second round of
funding yesterday demand is
extraordinarily high and there are
already twice as many users accessing
the system as or any day under the first
round and one of the things that the
secretary of the Treasury told me is
that the amounts are much more loans
it's much smaller amount so we like to
hear that because we're looking at the
small amounts of smaller businesses and
that's what we want nonetheless we're
processing loans that at pace never
achieved before in the first 24 hours of
the second round of funding we've
handled over 30 percent more loans than
any previous day of the program so far
we've processed an amazing 450,000 loans
totaling over fifty billion dollars
that's in Phase two this is incredible
along with administrator Carranza and
secretary minuchin Ivanka has played an
essential role in spearheading this
important we should not which she should
not even have she want to sell people
completely from the beginning of my
administration of vodka has used
experience as an entrepreneur to fight
for the American worker nepotism she's
created many jobs that's what she did
when she first came in she just wanted
people to be able to get creative no job
training what remember two weeks ago
that she created 15 million jobs which
would be 10% of all jobs in the United
States this is this is weaponized
disinformation almost 15 million people
right 15 million she started off with a
goal of 500,000 500,000 completely the
entire and I'd like to ask if I might
have R to say a few words oh my god
what's exactly happening today what
success what happen is a nice week and
what her views are for what's going to
happen over the next period of time it's
going to be something I think it's going
to be very special and bigger and better
than anybody really understands let's
see if I'm right about wow vodka please
she shouldn't even be involved didn't
even be here thank you everyone and
thank you mr. president for convening
this incredible group of entrepreneurs
and small business owners who very much
represent the soul and the spirit the
the grit and the tenacity of it sounds
like she might have got her teeth too
big it seems to be impacting her speech
right is anybody else hearing that you
for for joining us here today and very
excited to hear your stories and hear
specifically about how you're going
through this challenge and how through
the payment protection program and
through the PPP you are able to keep
your workforce employed it's it's about
your businesses thriving and growing
within your communities it's about your
workforce who each of you cares very
dearly about and I'd like to make a
special call out of thanks to secretary
minuchin for his tireless work on this
front so if you'd like to come up and
join us that we would appreciate that
secretary
[Applause]
SBA administrator Carranza thank you
you've been such a champion for
America's small business if you'd also
like to come up and leave standa leavin
even closer to home and larry cudlow
thank God you do in fighting for for
American workers with that I would like
to kick us off by introducing Amy right
to come up to the stage and share with
us a little bit of her story she it is
management again that stemmed from
personal experience and very much her
her heart and it's been an honor getting
to know you Amy as you research a real
body the spirit this is surreal small
businesses around this country Amy
because of the PPP program was able to
rehire the 120 workers that she was
forced to like hey guys you know what
now those workers I'm gonna cut it I'm
gonna KIII can't there-there's no I
can't in good faith show this I just
can't do it it is a it is trash it is
like it is it is the it's like an old
piece of gum that you accidentally step
on except this is easy to get away from
and I've just I can't show you that I
can't show you that [ __ ] I just can't do
it it would be it's naughty I'm not even
respecting you there is no journalistic
value to that [ __ ] whatsoever okay let
me just thank people who are actually
making the world better okay Jessica
jingle has just doubled more than
doubled her patreon pledge we're gonna
call her number two today
Megan Curran has grabbed a membership
she's number three ardham anokhin is new
member number four at join pakman.com
james dossing is new member number five
at join pakman.com and Mary pupal is new
member number six today at join
pakman.com every single person that
signs up I can't tell you how much I
appreciate it
we've been hit very very hard by the
virus we lost almost 400 members last
month we've lost almost 300 members this
month and every single time somebody
goes to join pakman.com in Satta and
signs up
you really are helping us
and you're making it so that I don't
have to show you that [ __ ] press
conference I can cut away from it
because it's the right thing to do and
is you know we we were told over the
weekend that Trump was going to be
paring down the press briefings when you
look at the calendar and the schedule
you see that Saturday there was no press
briefing you see that Sunday there was
no press briefing Friday Trump did one
but he walked away without taking any
questions yesterday he did one where he
took limited questions and today just a
totally toxic propaganda event which I
cannot in good conscience show you it is
there it is of no value people asking
when has it start we're out we're out
it's it's it's still going on look I'll
go over without even showing the audio
it's still going on and we're just not
doing it we're just not oh my god and do
you guys understand what's going on now
right I hope everybody understands what
it is that they're doing here
did this have if you want to talk about
the word political prop and pandering it
is what's going on right now and it is
disgusting it is absolutely disgusting
William C says thank you for pulling
away from that garbage my pleasure
Brian Cole D hey Brian hope fatherhood
is treating you well Brian says please
don't show us the BS I think you're
absolutely I think we're doing the right
thing here because this it is evil what
was going on there was weaponized
propaganda and we simply can't do it
Jorah monofin says i can't show you this
[ __ ] love it dpe yeah i think it's the
right decision listen if you want to
watch that there is no journalistic
value whatsoever there it is a zero
value we learn nothing listen let me sum
it up for you everything's great and
trumps to thank for it that's the that's
the message that's all that it is and by
the way 60,000 people have died and it's
soon going to be 70 and it's not getting
any better
let me say thank you to tani Lezama who
is a new member number seven today
samuel cook is new member
Sammy will cook that's interesting is
new member number eight today and Laura
Newby is new member number nine I think
that we've made the right decision
I'm going to take the afternoon to
really work on some important stories
for tomorrow I'm sorry we're not
streaming longer but that is toxic and I
can't do it to you I can't do it to you
thank you for joining me and we'll be
back with much more content coming up
you